this one's interesting wired writer
suspended from Twitter after using
platform to solicit and receive Matt
Walsh's hacked materials Dal Cameron
said prove me wrong kids send Matt Walsh
DMS to and then posted his email address
they say on Wednesday wired senior
reporter Del Cameron was permanently
suspended from Twitter permanently after
he asked for an obtained hacked
materials from Matt Walsh's Twitter
account quote spoke with the hacker who
says he compromised Matt Walsh's account
and who was able to supply some
convincing proof they'd gain access to
his personal email account story to come
our storytk
I mean that means I think that means
coming soon a tweet just after midnight
read in a post to Mastodon Cameron
stated they just got permanently
suspended for publishing this story
linking to an article he wrote titled
the hacker who hijacked Matt Walsh's
Twitter was just bored another post
revealed that Cameron was suspended from
Twitter for violations of the social
media's policies against the
distribution of hacked materials the
story alleges that the hacker provided
screenshots of an apparent copy of Matt
Walsh's W-2 tax form which lists his
employer as bent key Services LLC the
publisher of the daily wire a direct
message on Twitter from Shapiro from
2017 emails between Walsh and the
conservative commentator Crowder host of
later with Crowder's podcast dated March
14th etc etc I don't want to go through
all that because I don't want to
actually reveal any of that private
information but this just goes to show
in my opinion many of these corporate
journalists they're working in collusion
with in tandem with the people who are
sending threats who are intimidating
there was a story of I think it was a
Conde Nast executive who was um
he was uh he was gay and I think he was
trying to have some kind of gay hookup I
can't remember the exact story but a
blackmailer got access to the
information and said if you don't give
me money I will give this to journalists
and I think it was Gawker I could be
wrong but the journalists were like we
would love to publish this and and
basically collude with a blackmailer
what Dell Cameron is doing here this
wired reporter is basically saying we
will be the the information laundering
service for those that want to destroy
your life and harass and intimidate and
cause you harm
so Matt Walsh who clearly has
ideological enemies will seek out the
the enemies will seek out any means by
which they can cause damage to him and
this is quote unquote journalists the
great irony of this is the journals who
I think very few people on the right
have any respect for anymore but but
they're they're understanding what
you've pointed out Tim which is that
they just work with these political
operatives but the journalists always
present themselves as the brave fourth
estate speaking truth to power on the
front lines and the irony here is Matt
Walsh is actually one of the most
important journalists in America right
Matt Walsh is doing much more important
journalistic work than any of these
people at any of these liberal
Publications and so they left-wing
political operatives are doing
everything they can to attack an actual
journalist by the name of Matt Walsh I
think Matt's gonna Sue this guy didn't
name him by name but he tweeted an hour
ago I've also made note of the members
of media openly solicited stolen
information from my phone there I'll be
I'm kind of talking like Matt would talk
to there will be consequences there too
fortunately we can afford very good
lawyers oh wow let me uh let me try and
pull that up that is on his Twitter
account
yeah Matt pulls no punches man
metaphorically spiritually you don't go
after that guy well this is also the the
reason that we sell a lot of chocolate
and razors and why daily wire is a
for-profit company is the only way to
fight back against any of these people
is to have a lot of money that we can
translate into power so that these guys
don't do what they're doing against Matt
or me or Brett Cooper just got booted
from Tick Tock today yeah wow they're
just I don't know this is the last 48
hours has been like open season on The
Daily wire but the reason that we need
to have a lot of money is so that we can
fight back and punish these guys when
they do it so they don't do it against
everybody else could it have anything to
do with the launch of the delicious she
her him chocolate bars by Jeremy's
chocolate I'm more of a he him man
myself uh you know Media Matters is
going to collect that one out it's good
the not one is very good but the she
heard it's actually yeah it's really
good yeah and I was uh this is actually
really funny I looked on the back of the
ingredients fair trade cocoa butter fair
trade cane sugar dried milk powder fair
trade cocoa powder
soy free
it actually it actually does say soy
seed oils oh really yeah you're right
I'll tell you something so Jeremy
insists that if he is going to tell a
joke it has to be a very very expensive
joke and so we decided early on we could
have just sold schlock kind of products
and people probably would have bought
them and it would have been fun no
we insist upon the highest quality
products that we can can possibly find
there's a lot of crunchy people at DW my
wife is has really pushed for that as
well so it's extraordinarily high
quality stuff it is really good yeah
like no no joke crunchy people like they
like I was just kidding because I was
crunchy I only read that because I saw
the soy free in it
could be adjacent right-wing person yeah
this has been one of the big
realignments is that the when I was
growing up when we were all growing up
the libs were the crunchy people and the
conservatives were just slopping down
all sorts of corporate hormone-injected
food and now it's completely the
opposite it's the libs lining up for
just soy Seed Oil City and it's the
conservatives who are buying the 12 eggs
yeah there was there was like a like a
sea change in 2012 or something about
Barack Obama and people just following
the media narrative and just buying the
Pfizer and buying the Coca-Cola and
doing what Trump you know he loves
McDonald's he loves McDonald's and I
love that he loves McDonald's I agree I
I won't go near it you know he he is
more aspartame now than man I would say
and it has preserved him fairly well so
maybe that's a good argument and a well
done steak that's organic sustains him
no high fructose corn syrup no corn
syrup oh no there's let's see one two
three four ingredients in this thing
that's college educated chocolate right
there well these days I guess probably
not you know let me let me let me read
mad Walsh's statement that I was
actually gonna do that Matt wall said
over the last year my family has been
harassed threatened doxxed and now we
can add hack to the list apparently the
hacker had an Insider who gave him
access to my phone a lot we still don't
know but we're finding out and there
will be consequences he says I have also
made out of the members of the media who
openly solicited stolen information from
my phone there will be consequences
their consequences there too fortunately
we can afford very good lawyers yeah
yeah we're um
we're going to be suing ourselves band
camp
so uh they took down me Bryson gray five
times August probably a couple others
um I don't know how much I should say
though
but uh apparently they're lying publicly
and internally about what happened so we
actually have you know I probably
shouldn't say too much but now I gotta
know you can't just but but for legal
reasons like because we're gonna enter
litigation most likely probably can't
say too much but I guess in this regard
perhaps it would be good that they know
this that we actually uh have received
uh
I'll keep it as light as possible
let's just say I have evidence that
they're spreading uh defamation to
defend to to preempt uh right we were
our our band and several others were
removed without notice we don't know if
they're holding our money we don't know
what's going on and so to justify that
apparently
they're lying about what really happened
but you know we'll see it should come
out in Discovery but I digress I bring
that up simply to point out
very good lawyers from the daily wire
this should need to be taken this is
really important conservatives for a
long time we've just been so nice and I
still think we should be just and do the
right thing and virtuous but we got to
be a little less nice okay I think we
need to start wielding power a little
bit more I think we've got to engage in
lawfare people always think that the
threshold for defamation suits is too
high because of the ridiculous standards
set by New York Times versus Sullivan
one that decision should have been
overturned it's ridiculous it should be
much easier to sue people for
intentionally lying about you but but
two
you can see now when conservatives push
back at all and when we've got a little
power and money behind us people cave
Rolling Stone caved Daily Beast caved
when they defamed me after the CPAC
speech and we're gonna sick the same
kind of lawyers on the people that went
after Men what happened with that when
they defamed you so they came out they
said that I called it CPAC to eradicate
transgender people they rewrote what I
said they put words into my mouth and
then dailybeast called me genocidal so I
tweeted out I said you know this is
defamation this meets the actual malice
standard yeah and I had some pretty
important constitutional lawyers who
agreed with me Senator Mike Lee came out
right away as a supreme court litigator
U.S senator he said this this meets that
standard you should sue these guys a
number of other people did those guys
went running I'm sure the editors got a
call from their lawyers that said you
got to change this because though the
standard is high you have crossed it so
they they caved in two seconds and it
just it just takes a little bit of
Courage I sometimes think that the the
libs they're like the sand people in
Star Wars you know
yeah they try to inflate their numbers
they see but they're they're cowards and
they don't they don't have really a lot
on their side so if you just have a
little bit of backbone they're not
impossible to defend and that's so right
and that's why the anhyzer thing I think
is so important because it's the easiest
yeah and you can already see that
Anheuser-Busch is kind of freaking out
about it but I guess in that regard uh
Jeremy's beer one uh listen I texted him
this morning I texted him this morning I
said man I know you're busy you're doing
a million things you have dropped the
ball here okay and you you clearly
there's too much money floating around
the daily wire we we're too cash
positive you gotta burn that money on a
beer company so that we can all learn
something here's what we're gonna do we
here at timcast are going to make a
generic website
and we're going to get a URL that can be
Universal and we'll call it I don't know
like you know uh
something product uh great great product
whatever and then whichever brand makes
the first step over the line in some
kooky wokeness we'll immediately mock up
some graphics drop it on the site and
start selling whatever it is and then
worry about sourcing it later yes of
course of course and the Budweiser thing
here has has been instructive because
yeah Budweiser loses six and a half
billion in market cap they could have
gotten that back if they would just shut
up it's unbelievable they keep changing
their story every single day but I
should apologize it's very they can
apologize but initially they defended it
then they tried to pretend they didn't
know about it then they tried to split
the baby with this crisis communication
stuff then they made that stupid horse
commercial that appealed to nobody and
so they keep blowing it here but the
bigger story I think is not even the the
hit to Anheuser-Busch I think the bigger
story is the hit to Dylan Mulvaney's
brand because I'm not convinced after
this huge unprecedented blowback against
Bud Light do you think other companies
are going to be so quick to sponsor this
guy they made
and there will be some brands that will
do it for sure woke Brands and leftist
companies will absolutely celebrate it
yeah and bigger companies are going to
say look we appreciate you bringing this
offer to us we're not interested at this
time it's going to be very just do the
brand Olay take him on after Bud Light I
thought Olay already had it it's hard
he's got like a dozen sponsorships it's
insane yeah but I I tend to agree with
you Tim I just think six and a half bill
in market cap that's a lot to lose okay
and I I always I think it's important to
stress this point for those who watch
all the episodes you've heard me say it
but just whenever I repeat stuff like
this in multiple episodes I understand
it's because not everyone watches every
show but uh Dylan Mulvaney is not trans
and this was said to me by multiple
trans people citing one very powerful
example Dylan Mulvaney making a video
pointing to his bulge and saying look at
my bulge look at my bulge the issue is
that people who are gender dysphoric
feel pain depression and anxiety from
those those attributes that's what
they're suffering from gender dysphoria
quite literally would be a person saying
like don't look at me don't look at this
part of my body it causes me anxiety
Dill Mulvaney making a video saying met
women have bulges look at my bulge is
the antithesis of what gender dysphoria
is supposed to be Yeah you mentioned
earlier the time for being nice is not
now and I agree because like nice is
like oh someone's gonna say that they're
a girl when it's a guy and I'm like okay
I'll just not say anything because I
want to be nice now be nice it's
different I'm being friendly I'll tell
you to your face what I think but I
still love you that's being friendly and
I think what it is is meekness we need
to be meek which is humble and kind but
carry a big sword and do not mess around
this is something Jordan Peterson has
talked about a lot the meek shall
inherit the earth it's the ones that are
vastly wealthy and not afraid to speak
the truth to someone but also willing to
listen
that's I I think I don't know that
Jordan was the first to say that but I
do like the idea the meek shall inherits
the Earth yeah that's good yes I think
it's from from the Bible books he was
explaining how people think weak and
meek are the same thing and that's a big
misconception yeah no it's it's a very
important point and you know when we try
to parse the truth of this issue because
I agree Tim there's obviously something
weird going on with Dylan Mulvaney here
that isn't true of all people who have
sexual confusion but there are different
types of transgenderism this is Dr Ray
Blanchard made a point that there he
discovered two different types of
transgender people which is uh
homosexuals who like the idea of being a
woman and uh people with autogynophilia
people who have a sexual fetish who who
are aroused at the prospect of dressing
up like a woman that's in the
traditional cross-dressing the first one
would be gender dysphoria is that what
you're saying well they're both a kind
of a gender dysphoria but that it's it's
a really complex issue a good analogy
for this would be body and Tech disorder
which body Integrity disorder shares a
lot of the same attributes obviously
it's a defective perception about your
body it is often sets in early on
between the ages of 8 and 12. there may
be some mapping onto the brain to
explain it though a lot of those studies
seem kind of a little shallow as
well and often though not all the time
this disorder is associated with sexual
arousal that it has an association with
a kind of a paraphilia or a sexual
fetish so it's virtually identical well
uh transgender I will add to that
there's three different kinds that I
believe uh that we've seen publicly at
the two you mentioned but then Dylan
Mulvaney represents a third and that is
pseudo gender pseudo transgenderism
professional actor professional actor
Dylan Mulvaney is just trying to be
famous
Relentless self-promoters that use
transgenderism as a way to infiltrate
institutions of power that might be a
little bit overthinking it delmo Vance
like I'm going to be famous ooh look at
this it's giving me attention so I'll
use both of those examples let's assume
uh I think it was Michael malice who
said that Dylan Mulvaney is acting out
of fetish and and this probably comes
from Michael's uh personal uh uh
friendships with with trans individuals
I thought you're gonna say his personal
perversions
Michael's friends with some trans people
right and this is probably the
experience his head with them and things
that they've explained to him so is
Dylan Mulvaney acting out of fetish I
don't believe so if it is I think it was
Leah Thomas who was accused of being
what they call AGP Auto gynophilic
meaning that it's a fetish that they are
they're aroused by this
um well Dylan Mulvaney would not be
making the video singing look at my
bulge look at my bulge because the
fetishes look at my look at me I'm a
woman right if it was gender dysphoria
where the person experiences
a set of dysphoria from looking in the
mirror and seeing the wrong body they
also would not sing about their junk
Dylan Mulvaney fundamentally
misunderstanding what transgenderism is
made a video singing women have bulges
because this is just he's like well for
years you know not all trans people have
dysphoria and that's okay not all trans
people take hormones and that's okay and
then essentially anybody can adopt the
identity with zero consequences well I
mean this is just modern wokism and
leftism it's just like definitions mean
nothing and but I do want to stress this
post-modernism that book right there you
know I've never actually looked into it
I've seen the screenshots and it's it's
the book genderqueer and uh you will
probably not be surprised to learn that
in the book the woman who claims to be
non-binary explains that she's on an
auto androphile meaning that her desire
to be perceived as a male is rooted in
her sexual arousal from being treated as
a male of course so when this this woman
is a teacher talking to Children telling
them to say that she's a man she
explains it's actually her fetish to be
perceived that way she's including
children in her sexual arousal which I'm
surprised conservatives more concerns
haven't actually looked at this and and
said hey wait a minute first of all it's
kind of hard to look at you yeah well
there's a lot in there she couldn't read
till she was 12. it's why we're peeing
in the yard she was not so she was not
socialized properly by her parents she
never shaved her legs she never showered
she would wear crusted dried pads for
for days on end to the point where she
smelled like feces in the school had to
pull her aside say something is wrong
here and then she later got on to
explain how she is sexually aroused at
the thought of being perceived as a man
and that she pushes that onto other
people right I think conservatives would
do a great service understanding that
the libs are open about this though
that's why they say don't kink shame
right don't don't I think now on social
media you're not allowed to make fun of
people's fetishes no matter how weird I
think that's one of the rules on some of
the big Tech platforms and this follows
naturally from the idea that your sexual
desires no matter how deviant are some
wholly protected matter thanks for
watching this clip from the timcast IRL
podcast hang out with us live Monday
through Friday at 8 pm and become a
member over at timcast.com for
uncensored remember only shows exclusive
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time